you
hi everyone it's Jerry here's a
memorable game from 1991 between Nigel
short playing on the white end against
Yan timin let's see what exactly
happened in this game that makes it so
famous efore by short Tim in replying
with the aliens defense that nights
given a kick this often happens Black is
prepared for this knows it's coming
95 d4 and now d6 immediately putting
pressure on white center on this space
invader pawn the one that is in blacks
camp this is the hyper modern approach
that's the type of opening Black is
running with here the hyper modern
approach says go ahead build your center
but I will apply pressure to it in short
order so that's what happens in this
game there's a fight over these two
central dark squares going on white can
go for some great build-up in this game
namely the four pawns attack c4 and f4
not the case in this game
white places an emphasis on rapid
development in this one and securing the
e5 strong point Knight f3 g6 Bishop C
like b6 and white keeps the bishop on
this nice long diagonal running from a2
to g8 the g8 Square will at some point
be occupied by the king so that can't be
so bad to have your bishop opposite the
enemy King following up Bishop g7
placing pressure on white centre while
you feels comfortable enough already
committing the Queen in general probably
a little bit early to make a queen move
but fully justified here Evie 2 is a
fine post securing a 5 why am i drawing
so much attention to e5 it's because the
e5 pawn very often acts as a catalyst
for an attack against the black king
side so this section of the board is
what I'm referring to why is this so
well what is the most efficient defender
for blacks King side and from what
Square does that most efficient defender
stand best on well that pieces name is a
night and that squares f6 the very
square that the e5 pawn controls now a
couple of reasons why night stands well
from f6 again just a quick point there
will be no Queen quickly coming out in
this direction
very conveniently stop some queen coming
out in that direction of course there's
a problem that are controlling h5 but it
guards to a lot of nice squares from f6
it has a maximum number of moves from f6
8 possibilities
is taken away because of the e5 on and
on top of this we might also say what
more well the King Knight has now been
converted into a queen side specific
piece continuing black continues to put
pressure on the white centre is there a
fear of Bishop g4 at this point there
isn't if there was great enough fear at
this moment right here light would play
h3 Bishop g4 however is not yet a threat
so white gets on with castles and black
does the same only at this point does
right now play h3 this is an important
defender of the white center of the
white ePHI pawn now if instead of
castles if black lent with Bishop g4
what's the issue with this well yes this
Bishop is pinning the knight but at the
same time the bishop is unprotected and
in this case that can be taken advantage
of Bishop takes g7 and Knight to g5
Queen takes bishop next so only after
black castles do we have h3 primary
function stop the pin secondary function
flight square however I don't know if I
feel so confident saying that that is a
flight Square for this game continuing
we have a5 a4
d take C D take C Knight d4 the Knights
are exchanged in now e5 is struck out
twice white can defend it with now rook
to e1
now we have e six so e five has been
maintained this may strike some is a
little bit awkward you know the
light-square bishop what's going to
what's going to happen with this guy
where is he going to go some may think -
let's say play Bishop Bishop to f5 and
only then play e6 but an issue with that
is well he's really short on squares now
in fact he would be trapped with g4 so
it's not so easy to deploy this light
square bishop in an active way at least
not straight away can we see that
happening moreover black does not want
to see II 6 happen that e5 pawn running
even deeper into blacks camps so that is
stopped cold with d6 at the same time
this weakens f6 this is now a hole and
the bishop is pretty much the lone
defender for blacks King Knight d2
where's the Queen Knight going well the
Queen Knight whites Queen Knight is
heading towards the King side and blacks
K Knight drifted towards the Queen side
that's a it's going to factor in okay
more pieces are now drifting towards the
Kings side and blacks King side and
there's again just that one key defender
so 95 9 f3 clean c5 Queenie 4 okay here
comes the greatest attacking piece the
Queen's looking to sweep over to h4 and
then white looks to eliminate dark
square bishop
and then key in on these two gaps in
blacks position f6 and h6 lack at this
point is now sensing danger offering a
queen exchange something that white
declines in fact not only is black
offering a queen exchange but black is
offering up a pawn at this point
white can at this stage capture the
knight and then win a pawn but black
would have the bishop pair and there is
some compensation that black would have
by giving up that pawn and the attack is
much more difficult to realize now that
things have also opened up a little bit
more white declines the pawn offer white
declines also this offer of a queen
exchange in plays Bishop to c4 and with
this is content is fine with having a
damaged Queen side structure
this is what happens this right now is
what white is signing up for when the
move Bishop c4 is plate because what's
the follow up Knight b6 this bishop is
now struck at twice and white says go
ahead take my Bishop b3 ruin my
structure on keeping the Queen's on
Queen side is killed terrible structure
double isolated pawns and an isolated
pawn but white is going for the black
Kings throat first rook to e8 Bishop e3
was a threat skewering the queen and
rook he only had two options right if he
goes to d8 y can develop with tempo so
he's just staying clear of that yeah for
it to d8 there's Bishop g5 and then if
you want to keep the rook on the open
file you'd have to go here and that's
maybe a little bit awkward to do that
maybe the bishop wants to make use of
that square anyhow in the game it was
rook to e8
de pies the open file and interferes
with this quick reposition of the light
square bishop so black has to work a
little bit harder to get this guy
activated and if he can't move there's
no worry of this guy moving so how does
black complete development here notice I
mean white could look to immediately go
in for Queen h4 or Bishop h6 but first
says you know let me occupy an open file
and by doing so I'm interfering with
what it is black wants to do it's nice
if you combine those two with the move
improve one of your pieces and at the
same time prevent what it is your
opponent wants to do rook to d1 does
just that there will be no Bishop to d7
there will also not be b6 because the
rook would be hanging so that's another
reason to leave the Queen on e4 for just
one more move in the game Queen c5 Queen
h4 now d6 this
to e3 let's see where the queen is gonna
go exactly she has some choices here she
goes to c6
she's now not going to be around to
let's say control the dark square so
easily because of this decision for the
Bishop to kind of take a pit stop first
on e3 and question the Queens Post she's
now on c6 she can't run back to f8 so
easily
each six only now only after chasing the
Queen away from the sea 5-squared do we
have white looking to exchange dark
square bishop s' black seeing that this
is the key defender for the King side
I'm going to keep that Bishop on black
says and now we have Rick to d8 so what
is white looking to do White's now
saying well if you don't want to trade
bishops I'm going to look to checkmate
you on the back rank because my bishop
from h6 is controlling this flight
square there should be seven
this isn't any issue the night cannot be
kicked away from f3 there's no issue on
g2 because of this battery no problem
here for white light now doubles last
piece in the ball game at this point
black is well what is black thinking I
need that flight square I need to make
sure I don't have an issue on my back
rank if black captures the rook this is
going to be an issue because at this
point Bishop g7 we would now have Queen
e7 and this is a big problem rook takes
rook and eventually we're going to have
checkmate so before any captures are
made on d8 in other words we have black
returning to g7 saying you know what
alright I think it's best for me to have
the dark square Bishop soft but still
this is going to be an issue for Team
black a best move here
rook 8 to d7 white wants to keep pieces
on the board
both of these rooks are active and both
of blacks rooks are passive notice both
are biting at well they're just staring
at their own pawns and the white rooks
what do they do they control the only
open file in the game
in this rook now from d7 exerts some
seventh-ranked pressure it feels as if
just these two rooks and the bishop
feels like their presence isn't even
felt here so what follows is rip to f8
sensing some additional pressure against
f7 there was a threat in fact to capture
the bishop and then give give a check on
f6 and crash through so Rick to f8 it is
dark squared Bishop SAR exchanged rip to
d4 so already there's some idea of maybe
Queen f6 and the rook sweeping in we
have all pieces attacking the black king
or to e8 tough to suggest a good move
here for black if Bishop to c8 is played
here this is already running into mate
with rook takes f7 rook takes f7 and we
have some back rank issue here for black
eventually we would have mate so Bishop
to c8 not a good option here first the
rooks are over here maybe next lack is
looking for Bishop to c8
in comes now Queen a6 check King g8 and
now h4 so what's the idea with h4
this problem wants to get to h6 and then
Queen g7 game over the dark squares are
very weakened then as soon as the dark
square bishop SAR exchange that's the
that's the end result of that dark
square bishop exchange you're really
really weak on the dark squares so how
do you stop this pond from running up to
h6 h5 is pretty much the only way to do
it if you're playing h6 we would still
have h5 and if black tries to keep
things closed
well that's dropping h6 and yeah lights
crashing through there so
h4 is met with h5 that creates a couple
key weaknesses here g6
and g5 and so what piece is not playing
in this position and this is what makes
this game so cool
there's one piece that's not playing we
got the Queen
two rooks the night the last piece the
King where is he going
well he now sees a path into the black
position you can't get upon 2 H 6 but
yeah with a little bit of time this King
is going to sneak up to h6 control g7
and then there's going to be mate on g7
what is black do about this
unfortunately there's not much you can
do
to see RIPTA c8 is played if Bishop to
seed is played Y can already go in for
Knight g5 and on Bishop takes rook
there's rook f4 and white is crashing
through on f7 next and there's nothing
that black can do to stop that
Queen a8 Knight takes f7 and there's not
going to be any defense here rook takes
Queen takes Queen takes d7 and yeah this
is going to be an issue 14 black there's
no defense against the pressure against
f7 if black goes in for Bishop to c8 at
this point yeah
Bishop c8 Knight to g5 too much pressure
against f7 could pitch a rook it's
because these guys are so strong and the
e5 pawn is again this e5 pawn is acting
as a great catalyst in this game so
let's see how this one finishes up rook
c8
white continues King f3 how can you stop
this unfortunately there's a lot of back
and forth
not too much you could do about it
Bishop c8 now tried but yeah you're just
way too slow by this point after King to
g5 it is at this point that timin throws
in the towel he resigns there is no
defense Bishop takes rook here well two
main - King h6 Queen g7 mate
else King here well this pawn is now
pinned Queen takes g6 Queen h6 and we
can even play King f6 here same idea
Queen comes in next to g7 can only stop
mate for one move
checkmate on g7 next taking full
advantage over the dark squares that's
all for this video
pretty cool game it's an old one and
holdi but a goodie feel free to leave
any feedback to this one
the real key points were the pawn on e5
acting as a catalyst for that King side
attack and white then looking to
eliminate the only King side defender
getting rid of the dark square bishop
s-- made the dark squares on the blacks
King side vulnerable and we saw them
these dark squares taken full advantage
of in this short King walk
anyhow that's all for this video feel
free to leave any feedback in the
comment section below and as always I
hope you got something out of it that's
all for now take care bye
you